翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
子どもたちにこんな話を
したことはないでしょうか？
世界には貧しい国や地域があって
６秒に１人の子どもが
食べるものがなくて死んでしまう
食べられることに感謝して食べなさい！
さて 結果はどうでしょう？
子どもたちはその直後の夕食で
「あれ嫌い」「もうおなかいっぱい」
と言って
ご飯を残そうとします
私はそんな時
海外の貧しい地域のご飯を食べてもらいます
例えばウガンダの「ポショ」という料理です
このポショという料理は
白いトウモロコシの粉を
熱いお湯で練ったものに
じっくり煮込んだ豆をかけて食べる料理です
そして 白いトウモロコシや豆は
雨が少ない痩せた土地でも育つ
強い野菜だという話 —
この一皿だけで１日を過ごさないと
いけない子どもたちも多い話 —
小さい子どもたちが戦争に巻き込まれ
銃を持ち 兵隊に行かされる話をします
すると 子どもなりにイメージを膨らませ
きれいにご飯を食べてくれることがあります
私は世界の料理を作るシェフです
現地の方に教えていただいた料理を
作っています
また 世界の歴史や国際問題に
興味を持ってもらう手段として
世界の料理を食べてもらうという
体験をしてきました
例えば 日本の難民の問題 —
私たちのすぐ近くにある この大事な問題を
もっとたくさんの方に
もっと真剣に考えて欲しいと思いました
私たちの多くはエチオピアやトルコの
難民のことは知っていても
日本に難民がたくさん来ていることを
知りません
そもそも なぜ日本に来たのか？
日本に来ても なぜ難民申請が通らないのか？
日本に来ている難民の方が
どんな生活をしているのか？
そんなことを考えたことがある方は
案外少ないのかもしれません
私は 難民をテーマにしたイベントを開催し
難民を支援されている団体の方に
お越しいただき
お話を詳しくお聞きしました
そして 日本への難民の多い
ミャンマーという国の家庭料理を作り
みなさんと一緒に食べました
この「チェッタアールヒン」という料理は
インドの影響を受け スパイスのよく効いた
ご飯に良く合う
日本の肉じゃがのような料理です
ちょっと想像してみてください
みなさんがこのチェッタアールヒンを
夕ご飯で食べています
「ん〜 おいしい」
でも 次の瞬間 —
「バーン！」とドアが開き
兵隊が押し入ってくる —
そんな状況です
想像できますか？
当然 夕食どころではない —
転げるように逃げることになるでしょう
家も家財も捨てて逃げる
ひどい話では 子どもを捨てては
逃げられないという話もあります
逃げるのに必死です
まさしくこのような状況に置かれた人たちが
いるんです
こんな話をチェッタアールヒンを食べて
考えたのです
イベント終了後 嬉しいことに
継続的に支援をしてくださる方や
大学で自主的にサークルを立ち上げる若者も
出てきました
世界には 難民以外にも
たくさんの問題があります
私はそのたくさんの問題についても
料理を通して考えてみてほしい
と思いました
そして あるアイデアを思いついたのです
2010年『世界のごちそうアースマラソン』
というイベントを開催しました
２年間で世界中の料理を作り
みなさんに食べていただくイベントです
韓国から始まり 最後は日本 —
世界一周の旅をするように
全部で195か国の料理を作りました
料理は２週間で４か国の料理が提供されます
これがその時 お配りしたメニューです
世界の歴史や文化
その国のメニューが書かれています
これならお客様と世界中の問題について
話し合うことができる —
例えばアメリカ南部の郷土料理「ガンボ」では
黒人差別の問題を話し合いました
ガンボは ミシシッピー川で獲れるザリガニや
鶏肉を材料に使っています
中でも オクラを必ず入れるのが特徴です
オクラはアフリカ原産 —
奴隷貿易時代に奴隷船に乗って
黒人と一緒に運び込まれたのでは
ないかという説があります
アメリカ南部にオクラが運ばれて
現地の食材と出会い
ヨーロッパのスパイスと合わさり
現在に受け継がれてきた —
つまり白人文化と黒人文化が融合した状態で
料理が誕生したというわけです
この「ガンボ」という一皿に
黒人奴隷の悲しい歴史や
入植者の横行を見ることが
できるというわけです
「この一皿に歴史が混在してるのが
よくわかるね」
「こんなにおいしいのに
悲しい歴史があるなんて なんだか皮肉だね」
と ガンボを食べ 背景を知り
差別を考えるきっかけにしました
中国籍の女性の方が
「私も小さい頃 差別を受けたから
よくわかる」という話をしてくださり
身近な差別やいじめ —
それらを無くすには 相手の立場に立つ —
想像力を養う
といったことが大切ではないか？
という話に進展しました
料理と一緒に歴史や文化を知る
アースマラソンは
差別を始め
支配する国々、戦争、食糧問題 —
世界が平和になるにはどうしたらいいか など
様々な問題を 私達のこととして
考えるきっかけになったのです
世界には 様々な国があり
それぞれ 大きな問題を抱えています
それはテレビや新聞で
知ることも多いでしょう
でもそれは 遠い世界の他人事であって
自分達のこととして考えることは
少ないのではないでしょうか？
ある意味 それは仕方のないことです
人は見たり聞いたりしただけでは
なかなか自分事にできないし
具体的な想像がしにくいのです
私は今までの経験から
問題の起こっている国や人の事を考えながら—
その国の料理を食べる という体験が
とても大切ではないか—
と考えるようになりました
「考えながら食べる」という体験は
遠い世界の事を
自分たちの事として
想像し 考えるきっかけになるのです
世界の料理は
遠い世界の事を
自分事として感じさせる —
ツールとしての価値がある
と言えるでしょう
私は世界の料理を学ぶため
たくさんの国を訪れましたが
現地の方と関わり
語りつくせぬほどの
思いやりや優しさに触れました
それと同時に
貧しさや差別—
飢餓で苦しむ方の姿も見てきました
衝撃でした
なんて不平等なんだろう？
なんて不公平なんだろう？
同じ地球に生きているのに
怒りにも似た感情です
そして 自分が頭ではわかっていたことが
自分事にできていなかった事に
衝撃を受けたのでした
私の願いは
みなさんが世界の国々の問題に
興味を持ってくれることです
興味を持ってください
考えてみてください
自分事にしてください
それが世界を良くする一歩になります
そして 世界の料理を食べてみてください
世界の料理は 私たちと世界を近づけ
より良い未来への道標になる
私はそう信じています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）